fate news two words that have dominated
conversation about the role of the media
in the last three years the Trump years
where Donald Trump came up with a phrase
well this summer a play called fake news
in which a young journalist major scoop
turns out to be a major error that risks
his entire career will be performed at
the Edinburgh Fringe in joining us
tonight Oprah often though we've got the
play stars in the play and used to work
here Osmond how you doing I am good
thank you hi Stephen how are you it's
good to speak to you again we did work
together many years ago and it's great
to be on this side of the camera now
whether it is look talk us through the
play why did you want to write about
this so the reason why I wrote this play
is because well so as I just suggested
it you know I've been a journalist for
many years I've worked at Sky and other
organizations and I got to the point
where I was just genuinely fed up of
Donald Trump and other people saying
things like fake news or casting
aspersions on the media or you know CNN
which is a company that I then went on
to work for and it's like this is a
inaccurate and B it's unfair and it's
kind of insulting to sort of the great
people who I've worked with over the
years and the great work that people do
so I was like you know what I'm going to
take matters into my own hands
I'm going to tell this story of how I
think from my experience the media
actually works and I kind of wanted it
to be something that really sort of
showcased how ordinary people make up
the media is not just people in these
ivory towers pushing some agenda you
know as you'll know you meet weird and
wonderful people I did night shifts on
Sunrise and I can tell you there's all
manner of people who you meet and
actually night shifts are a theme of
this play but I really wanted to show
what the media is really like and to
show that it's just normal people doing
the best they can with frankly limited
resources so that's that sort of my
motivation in writing this yeah talking
to strange people husband Mike Kumar's
producing this show so you know how
weird it Mike you know you know how
weird it's going to be mm yeah look it
mean in terms of how do you think this
is going to go down with the crowds
because I mean you'd imagine it's
something which is quite sort of left
see like the Edinburgh Fringe there's
going to be a lot of people out there
who actually want to have a go at
mainstream media they it is a sort of
target at the moment yes and this is the
thing I wrote this play because I didn't
want to be too left or too right I
wanted to try and regain some more other
what I think is sort of common sense and
center ground I feel the problem we have
in society and something I address in
the play now is where we are becoming
far too polarized we are either kind of
agreeing with each other all on Twitter
if someone is espousing something or was
shooting down anyone who doesn't agree
with our opinions and it feels like we
have lost the art of debate in society
no one is allowed to have an opinion
anymore if it contravenes what most of
the people around you are saying so I
really wanted to make sure that this
show wasn't going to be anti Trump you
know it criticizes the Obama legacy as
well I didn't want it to be sort of like
what people might expect when they see
something like you know a titled fake
news I want to try and find that Center
ground and common sense but I do think
in politics that we kind of lost
slightly I just feel like we're far too
polarize so I hope that when people come
and see this show they will see that it
is not pushing any sort of agenda it is
not Trump bashing it really does have
something to say about how the media
works and how that is also reflecting
what is happening in society right now
so I really hope that people do take
that message on board and so far we've
had a couple of previews they've been
really good audiences you know I've been
really lucky to have great readers also
the show is now pretty much sold out
we're adding extra dates so if anyone is
interested in what this space so yes
fingers crossed that it will go down
well is it scary I mean obviously we you
know we think of you as being one one of
the producers is it scary then saying
actually this is something which I have
penned and that I am going to stand up
on the stage and perform yeah it's
absolutely terrifying I feel nervous
every time I go on stage but the thing
is I think that it's just a story that I
genuinely believe in so much and I think
that just helps you get over the nerves
and you obviously get used to it
since you know while being a journalist
I then went to drama school and like
trained in sort of acting and I've done
other shows and I've done a lot of
theater since but of course when you're
presenting your own work it is
nerve-racking because it's totally
exposing I wrote it myself and you know
it's all me I still don't let my family
watch it even though they've wanted to
come up and see it's just because very
personal but I think ultimately the
message of the play and what I believe
that I have to say overrides that and
luckily the response from audiences and
luckily critics as well has been so
positive that's just galvanized me on
the journey as I keep going and
hopefully there'll be more life in the
show yet I would love to see it on TV I
think TV is my natural habitat having
worked out anything there's a lot of
good stories and anecdotes which would
work well in a TV newsroom setting so
yes I feel really encouraged by it well
all you need to do to wrap it all up for
TVs to write the theme tune sing the
theme tune and then you've done
everything else really good to see you
thank you very much thank you so much
thank you everyone thanks